oh nope I didn't do it that time I got a
full snout full woo okay no let me just
try it again I'm a little rusty all you
got to do just close the old noston and
the oh boy I got more that
time where did you get
this I hope you get hit by a truck and a
dog takes a dump on your face nothing to
see here just a little hypoglycemic rage
oh that's so
smart Everybody
Run
[Applause]
okay the tree has been contained wait we
left a man
behind well Terry's trapped in the break
room forever only thing we can do now is
move on with our lives is what Terry
would have
wanted God bless us
everyone
yeah this is what happens when you're
naughty woo
Jake Jake Jake Jake did I say something
amusing to you answer me you son of a
[Music]
[__] hello my name is Adelaide I'd like
to report a crime so we're just doing
one of these every day oh you got it I
know you got it I want my
money okay okay it's just kind of
difficult U because the deflating out
now turn on the punk I'm very
claustrophobic tell me literally
everything everyone shut
up what the hell boy you almost killed
me I'm not going out in a St Mak an
accident Terry's going to die saving the
president or Terry's never going to
die huh what uh nothing let's make
out yeah all right hey yeah any you guys
play an instrument you know I play a
little bit of bazooki anybody else play
an ancient string at instrument no you
guys want to go to the beach it's
beautiful day just maybe like get out
there throw the disc around right hey
have you ever been to the Statue of
Liberty Captain have you have you ever
been inside like under the skirt like
what's up there do they build a you know
what I'm saying guys watch this I'm
going to
juggle hope you drown in a TB I hope you
have aneurysm after aneurism after
anur she'll be
okay darn it to heck the door is
closed Bar Bar Bar oh are there bars on
the window yeah why would W fake her own
death the same reason she visits Mexico
once a year and sucks the blood from all
the goats for kicks Terry call it in the
air heads or
tails neither oh my god did you just
fold my quarter and
half in the
[Music]
rain printer's
fixed oh
dang good job can you do it without
screaming
Pro Le wait a minute he's got a pulse no
wait that's my pulse no it's his pulse
no it's both our pulses he's alive I'm
alive we need more time someone do
something I got it de
gas
this is terrible you don't know what
you're doing Adam Sandler yeah that's
right I collect Antiquities I'm a
serious person uhoh my Fringe my
beautiful fren on fire I have an
STD I will stop at nothing to get that
trophy I'll shoot you all in the face if
I have
to go team You're a Grand Old Flag
you're flying flag I have a very funny
story about keeping my eyes moist
[Laughter]
nope still not getting our Vibe
[Music]
[Applause]
man I do not have a problem if I want to
play Crazy Cupcakes I will play czy
cupcakes quy is a
difficult word to say in anger but I
think I've made my feelings
clear we need ye the only thing that's a
little much around here are your
scrolled on eyebrows ye it's full
naked what are you waiting for I want to
see where your hair starts and stops
let's
Fiesta oh you got a
band
there know where to run you Dr me Rosa
and then you shi me to New Jersey first
of all rup second of all how'd you get
back here so fast if you get a box wet
enough it's very easy to bust out of it
no one ask any follow-ups everything is
totally under control Charles his paner
on fire Bo out the space heater get away
from the space heater I don't know where
it is I'm just going to run at full
speed no curse my beautiful bubble butt
see all Bo men are blessed with a flat
ass
now okay I know you have two bullet
wounds in your butt but you got to stop
calling them your butt holes Nikolas
Nash Nikolas Nash nikol Nash Nash Nash
nikol it's okay you say it the
wrong we made a joke
[Laughter]
together remember that very fancy Swiss
pen I got you for Christmas the one that
you keep in your pocket at all times
it's a taser
bro oh no
is it bleeding Charles is it bleeding
I'm going band you're going to have to
crawl inside his shirt and operate his
arms for him it's a ratou situation on
it no it's over one more time all right
one more time one more time one more
time one more time all right one more
time one more time God this reverse
psychology is a bus I'm the body sh stay
in character Roger gratitude gratitude
gratitude
gratitude she doing
[Music]
it did it oh that was great I love being
Independence I have to go to the
bathroom oh okay I hope
you shame shame for the last five years
all I've done is give a hoot about you
and what you think gave a hoot about you
as a boss gave a hoot about you as a
mentor I gave a hoot about you as a
friend she gave so many Hoots not
anymore after the way you've acted and
what you just said to Jake I don't give
a hoot what you think and I really don't
give a hoot if you decide to quit the
NYPD so do it I'm all out of Hoots I'm
hotess you guys it the podium
[Laughter]
you're crazy how did you pull this off
well it was good to see you Caleb send
me that
info